who should play evan in a movie i made a
video not so long ago but when i
realized i was an entrepreneur telling
my story and one of my youtube fans love
you guys valerie wrote in to say this
would make a great movie
and wrote this whole thing and broke it
down at the beginning enticing moment
progressive complications crisis climax
resolution and and laid out how the
whole movie should go and i really
enjoyed it and loved the extra effort
that was put into it what i want to know
from you guys is if there was an evan
carmichael movie who should play the
actor if it wasn't me i'm thinking like
big name actor who do you see playing me
on screen just a fun video let me know
what you think leave it in the comments
below i want you to tell me who should
play me in a big hollywood movie
let's see what comes in if you like this
video thumbs up below leave your comment
wish me to feel better
subscribe to the channel click my face
and i'll see you soon
i'm so sick right now